all righty time for another movie
retrospective and we're doing yet
another HP Lovecraft adaptation yet
another Stuart Gordon film yeah we do a
lot of these yeah well this is a good
this was like a good company making a
good series and you know and I had had
our boy in there was his name Jeffrey
Jeffrey Combs yeah we uh yeah you know
from beyond right I remember when I saw
it when it was when it came out then
didn't get to see it in movies I don't
know if I had if the obstacle release or
not um friends I believe it did yes oh
good I mean it came out a year after re
animator which is actually a pretty big
success and this is kind of it's a you
know in a similar kind of a Nasri
animator but you know it's it's kind of
like like I said it's sort of a loose
adaptation of an HP Lovecraft story
which is difficult from beyond this
one's actually closer to the story then
re-animator was but it still goes off
and very Stuart Stuart Gordon II
directions I remember when we first got
this like you said it was just right
after re-animator yeah and we would rent
him we would just rip up my buddies who
are back in high school they were new
yeah I don't remember where we rented
them from I don't think you could rent
these from Blockbuster I think there was
too much I think they were there they
were like n c---seventeen I think at
that time well this one particularly
when it first came out they did have to
trim out about 30 seconds to get an R
rating but um you know subsequently when
it was re-released later on they
actually restored the footage they took
out some of the gore and took out like
some of the SM yeah kind of stuff but
it's as far as I know it's all been put
back in there now because we actually
you know we watched it because I
remember it had Gore in there and it had
it had all what's-her-name and that sexy
outfit yeah Barbara crammed yeah and
button that the cop the black do is kind
of get enough water we were sure yeah
because that was really that was really
cutting edge back in then back in that
yeah yeah I think people like kind of
forget that this was like a pretty crazy
movie yeah they were all they all were
four yeah geez I mean it was like some
crazy [ __ ] it's still kind of crazy in a
way like if you watch it it just goes
off like in these batshit directions and
it's like this
really really
wacky like special effects they're
actually kind of remind me a little bit
of the thing yeah like some of the it
was the same guy wouldn't um I actually
was it I don't know no cuz Rob poutine
did this thing I don't think he did this
movie but um the but the creature
effects are like actually really similar
particularly the one part where you know
dr. Pretorius comes back and he's all
like armed amended from reanimate ER
came out and then excuse me
reanimate ER came out and then from
beyond and of course you had the evil
Dead's they were both out I think one
and two at this time yeah I'm pretty
sure and it was just like a whole new
world that was the direction [ __ ] was
going that was the way video
entertainment was going and we were just
you know it was we just loved it yeah
they're wondering how far it could go of
course you know we hadn't seen saw or
anything like that let you know yet I
don't think we would have liked those
there was something about these old
movies with the mixing kind of horror
comedy sex and humor all in the same
yeah you know it was like it was like a
full spectrum dominance over you we
liked it we really liked it like they
still make movies like that sometimes
nowadays but I feel like well
particularly was like the torture porn
kind of heyday um I like a lot of those
movies like I liked the first saw like
the first hostel was okay stuff like
that but a lot of those movies I think
um yes they're very violent they're very
gory but also they're kind of
mean-spirited yeah um a lot of the
movies from the 80s that were
over-the-top gory and stuff they didn't
have that same cynicism maybe yeah
because I mean movies like that
reanimate er from beyond Evil Dead
they're fun yeah and they were very
optimistic yeah they gave you a feeling
of optimism even though these were
horrible stuff happen to them yeah but
you would roll with it
you did yeah yeah it is kind of funny
that his head exploded you know oh yeah
I mean that's that's what I mean it's
like it's kind of an odd thing to say
but I do feel like there they had a
sense of fun yeah to them and I think
that's why a lot of people still like
they were taking us down into these new
directions and we were like well how far
can they go
this kind of entertainment and we'd
start wondering yeah what-what can
science do what happened if you really
could bring a person back from the dead
what if you really could build a machine
you know that would stimulate your
pineal gland and allow you to see into
another dimension yeah and that's what
this one is about exactly this scientist
who's all kinking into S&M builds this
thing called the resonator and it's just
like a cylindrical thing a bunch of
tuning forks on top of it and a computer
hooked to it and a bunch of power and it
would vibrate we resonate and if you
were in the range of this thing you
could come in contact with beings from
another dimension and they could contact
you you can see them they can see you
and then in that particular field they
could interact with you and I remember
that you know when this moment when we
first watched this movie during that
first scene when they turn the resonator
on and you see the little eels yes I
dimensional nails floating around yeah
it was like in the other dimension was
like a like an ocean which kind of is
like an HP Lovecraft type of theme yes
an aquatic over there even though you
didn't breathe the fish swimming through
the air you know going around the tuning
fork so I said Wow
because I remember me and my buddy Jason
saw that we just started tripping what
if that was really happy I didn't know
in another dimension things are swimming
around your light bulbs know that kind
of stuff it could be yeah and that was
just you know back in those days for our
generation it would just [ __ ] with your
mind you know we weren't really sure
what was possible and we still don't
really know maybe there is another
parallel dimension right now but the
Machine stimulated your pineal gland C
which is like some people believe it has
to do with kind of like psychic
abilities and if the third eye yeah and
it's pretty cool what happens you know
the this the people who come in contact
with this thing the little pine oil
glands starts getting bigger and bigger
I can't spoil it yeah we don't want to
see it's an old movie yeah it is a magic
taking about 1986 and like I said it's
closer to I mean the HP Lovecraft story
it's
actually a pretty early one of his I
think it's from 1920 and the story is
only about five pages long and it's just
like kind of it's it's almost a vignette
more than a story but it's actually has
the same premise of like a mad scientist
that invents a machine that lets you see
creatures in another dimension but the
the sexual angle yeah that Stuart Gordon
brought to the movie and a lot of the
you know a lot of the other kind of
stuff that happens in the movie was not
really in there but other than that it's
you know it's more similar like I said
then reanimate ER was I feel like and it
has more I know this is kind of a weird
thing to say but it has more of a
Lovecraftian feel to it like I said
because you're seeing something that's
there all the time right
but here's this machine that makes it
visible makes it visible and they
interact with it
yeah and then like not only can you see
these monsters another two but now they
can see you too yeah and now they're
gonna like pop your head up yeah they're
not all monsters they're like they're
just creatures yes some of them have
monstrous abilities it's pretty neat
yeah and there's kind of a little the
kind of alludes to a shag off because
you know what ends up happening is a guy
gets swallowed and his head gets
swallowed and the head goes into the
creature and the creature becomes the
man which is kind of how in in in in the
mountains of madness how the shoggoths
got intelligence they were like an
amoeba the swallow didn't solid an old
one and then the intelligence of the old
one went into the shag off and it shared
the information with all the other ones
and they rebelled yeah so which is kind
of like the thing the thing was kind of
based off a shag off you know what's
funny is that I saw like I was reading
some reviews on Rotten Tomatoes and IMDB
and stuff like never this movie just cuz
I was curious isn't what people thought
and like most of the reviews obviously
were very um you know very very positive
a lot of people really really love this
movie one of the funniest ones that
somebody said was like the thing but
pink
yeah well this creature is in another
universe or in the other dimension that
ends up getting and getting intelligent
you know I don't want spoiling all of it
it's basically kind of like a jellyfish
yeah it can it can change its form and
it can absorb things and so it's cross
between the the
the thing and a jellyfish yeah it is
pink this dimensions pink that is like
kind of cool about this and if any of
you have seen I don't know if it's still
on Netflix or not but there was actually
a pretty recent horror movie called
beyond the gates I think it came out in
2015-2016 something like that it
actually has Barbara Crampton in it you
know call back and it's obviously paying
homage to 80s movies in general but
specifically to the movies of Stuart
Gordon and it has the same lighting
scheme yeah as from beyond its where
everything is like cyan and magenta
right it's like almost like a like a
giallo ting but more like 80s neon style
a subscriber sent us a copy of this
movie in HD at least I don't know if you
rate quality but it almost looks like a
blu-ray quality and it looks better than
it ever did when we watched it on VHS
it's beautiful cool yeah and yeah a
bunch of colored lights and what's her
name the woman's that girl's name
Barbara Crampton yeah she's she's
wearing this like pretty BDSM outfit yes
Merry Widow through the whole thing
pretty cool yeah it looks good well then
yeah I think what a lot of people that
were teenage boys in the 80s I remember
fondly about the yeah Barbara Crampton
cuz she has that hold she's actually a
psychiatrist yeah but she has that whole
like sexy librarian thing where's all
the big glasses in the suit and
everything and then as the resonator
turns on because it's supposed to like
stimulate your pleasure centers yeah
arouses you you start drags you're not
supposed to be doing you know yes so now
suddenly and like I said I guess in the
80s it's like now everything's so old
hat but like in the 80s as big do like
very transgressing yeah yeah before the
internet you know
just imagine what that was about yeah
mainstream didn't do that and like I
said and honestly I think and you know
it's hard for me to say because I grew
up in the 80s with all these movies and
stuff but I still think that the effects
in this are really good I think they
really do that obviously a lot of
practical effects all practical very
goopy
a lot of creatures like I said it's
similar to the same
Kreacher there's lights different kinds
of blood pretty cool yeah I mean you
know you get to see [ __ ] Ken Foree
from Dawn of the Dead did gigant worm in
it and he gets to like fight a gigantic
worm in his underwear
yes all kinds of weird you know Ken
Foree was in his underwear the worm
wasn't wearing underwear so I said no
you know you get to see Jeffrey Combs
sucking out a woman's brain through my
jacket which man just eaten down to the
bone by swarm of little tiny creatures
that came out of the other dimension
yeah it's just happens fast yeah you
just go you know stuff poking out of
people's head like people get in their
heads but uh yeah it's like brains and
yes it's just this crazy crazy movie and
I love you know as much as I said when
we talked about castle freak that
actually Jeffrey Combs this is actually
a really good actor when he plays a
normal person obviously he's not playing
a normal person and this he plays
Crawford tilling gasps who's actually
the main character in the HP Lovecraft
story but in this one he's like the
assistant of the main doctor who was dr.
Pretorius who's the one that builds the
resonator yeah but since Pretorius gets
killed by one of the creatures then
obviously Jeffrey comes character is
accused of murder because no one
believes that this resonator is like
showing yeah Jeffrey comes character
pretty much it's pretty much just a guy
from you know Herbert West really is
Kanye he comes his way through pretty
much just Jeffrey Collins yeah it's not
quite as um I think when he played
Herbert West he was like a lot more so
more intense sardonic and like kind of
like I'm smarter than everybody yeah you
know he came across like that yeah
whereas in this one he comes across as
like kind of crazy but more earnest yeah
like he doesn't come across like it's
just kind of like you know kind of an
[ __ ] like condescending he doesn't
really have that when we were kids we
didn't really notice that we just
thought yeah but yeah that's that's her
at West with a different name
yeah I mean like I said that was one
thing that Stuart Gordon really liked to
do and why he used a lot of the same act
I mean obviously because there were old
friends and stuff but you know Stuart
Gordon came up in theater so he's like
so I was very used to the idea of you
know having a theater company and having
like all the same people like being in
here and he also pointed out too that he
wanted to do something similar to what
Roger Corman had done with the Edgar
Allan Poe adaptations worth it was the
same people invent looks like in
different roles we loved it you know we
loved it oh you saw that oh it's that
guy from yeah you know everything was a
callback yeah we wanted to see the same
actress over and over again when we were
watching this one these these movies and
like I said I think that's kind of the
cool thing about it too and because you
know Stuart Gordon develops like a
rapport with these particular actors and
he's like and plus he knows you know
they know that we're doing HP Lovecraft
and they might be asked to do some
strange things you know it's the same
audience - over and over again it was
following along with this so you know we
were eating it up yeah and it might mean
ooh we were yeah it's like I don't know
I don't know they're the movies are very
similar like this one in reanimate er
and you know I've heard arguments on
both sides like most most people like
reanimate or better but like this one
almost as much I have seen a few people
saying they liked this one better than
reanima special effects are better than
this one then reanimated I think yeah we
animator one probably I think they
probably I think that's what I think
they're a little bit better I don't know
if I could pick it's like they there are
similar movies but they're different
tones they have a different tone like
for one thing from beyond is not as
funny it doesn't have like the same
comedic element that re animator has it
has like funny moments in it but it's
not I don't think I'd call it a horror
comedy animator the reanimated
reanimated was so focused on dead bodies
are the Dead coming back this one is
about creatures from another dimension
parallel yeah so it's a different tone
it's not as morbid yeah more science
fiction yeah and so like I said that
that's why that's what I meant when I
said it had more of a Lovecraftian you
know it's a much more Lovecraftian story
this is not as good as Dagon though but
it's still good and again Dagon I feel
like that
that's a really different very different
vibe I mean even though it's the same
director you can tell it's the same
director or you could you know you can
tell it's the same team that made it but
that one is a much more serious movie
this one while more serious than
reanimate er is more like a straight
sci-fi horror with just some funny this
one's kind of to me kind of feels a
little bit more like Necronomicon yeah
that kind of along that line it's much
better yeah I think it is too and light
you know like I said it's it's it's a
really nice looking movie like I really
like the extreme lighting in it it gives
it like a really kind of otherworldly
kind of feeling to it I think they got
that from the Italians yeah their
problem yeah and yeah like I said it's
just very candy colors very neon color
and it's like kind of fun in that way I
really liked Ken forey's character who
was actually a cop that's going with
them to turn on the resonator because
you know they want to prove that Jeffrey
Combs characters and crazy like cuz he's
like I really didn't murder that guy was
just the game on the machine and they
send the psychiatrist you know played by
um Barbara Crampton she believes him but
you know they have to go to the house
and turn the resonator on so they can
prove that Jeffrey Combs it was not did
not actually murder dr. Pretorius
so and then they all kind of get sucked
into it and stuff like that but I really
really like the the ensemble of like the
three of them and so so I like that
aspect of it a lot and I like the fact
that they kind of put Jeffrey Combs more
in the you know more in the lead role
because in reanimate ER he was kind of a
lead role but then they had that other
guy too that was kind of Sharon's green
so it depends because there's about
three or four different cuts of
reanimate or someone stronger than the
other ones actually I haven't seen the
longest cut of it I'd like to see the
longest cut they're supposed to be more
in there yeah a lot more in there with
you know we're with Herbert West and
then the guy who ran the universe katana
Universal right yeah there was like a
lot of stuff evidently there is a scene
where the the guy from Miskatonic
University was named professor or
something rather I can't remember he
could hypnotize people and that was kind
of cut from the yeah remember we I think
we talked about that I remember it I saw
it on one of the cuts on the past that
might have been an old VHS cut cuz I
remember him hypnotizing somebody and
then he does it again later on and it's
a part of the film that got cut from
what I remember I missed I haven't seen
in a long time it's funny how much stuff
gets like cut out and like that you know
for years afterward there's like all
these different cuts of it like yeah
floating around and stuff and like I
said I think the same thing happened
with this because they had to cut out
you know however long it was like to get
an R rating which Stuart Gordon was not
happy about but as far as I know like
every version that's out there now I
think everything has been restored like
now everything is like the director's
cut so I'm not even sure if you can see
the cut up like our version and you know
theatrical cut I don't really know it's
funny because this is something that's
kind of interesting to me because you
know I I was interested in kind of like
the video nasty thing from the UK and
you know I read a lot about that and
it's funny because I think Americans
maybe think that movies are not cut over
here but they are yeah
it's just you don't really hear about it
I don't think I'm not sure this movie
ever had a u.s. theatrical release I
think it went direct to VHS maybe I
don't think this ever had a theatrical
release maybe we could look at the
Wikipedia yeah what does it say it says
release date October 24th 1986 so I
don't know if I think I mean I'm
guessing one in a blockbuster I think
well maybe well I'm sure maybe it was
just like a limited release
limit limited theatrical release and
then I remember we knew Orient we knew
about reanimate er yeah if there was a
theatrical release in our area we would
we would yeah I think it just showed up
and we just showed up at Blockbuster one
day another interesting thing about this
movie - very similar to Castle freak
this was also shot in Italy which he
probably wouldn't know now you would
let's do it I mean Stuart Gordon has
gone on record as saying this movie
would have cost fifteen million dollars
to make in the US but it only cost like
1.5 million Rock to make in Italy and
they feel so poorly Italian crew also
yeah part of the expense have been all
the Union stuff they would head down and
they are stay filmed at the at a studio
that had once been owned by
Dino De Laurentiis okay but actually he
didn't pay the taxes on it so it is so
it like repossessed its somebody's body
so it was like after so after Dino
dealer I'd says lost control over it run
this was one of the first movie that was
shot there
Dino cheetah what big Dino city which I
thought was very funny but yeah so I
that's the thing I don't I assumed this
had a theatrical release because like I
said the MPAA kind of came out and said
well you have to get an R rating you
have to take out this that and the other
thing they they actually told him to
take out much more than he actually did
take out but see I hear a lot of
directors doing this kind of thing over
there like well you have to take like
ten minutes out of this [ __ ] cuz this is
just unacceptable and then they'll be
like okay and then they cut out like
five seconds somewhere then they
resubmit it then they're just like
alright it's fine right I think they
forget because they see so many and it's
just like whatever close enough it's
like I'm it's the end of the day I don't
feel like so I think that's kind of what
they told them that he had to take out I
think the quote they gave him was
there's ten times too much of everything
wrong it's like you need to take all
this out and I think he only ended up
taking out about thirty seconds and then
they passed it for an hour but then
later on it was like but he was still
pissed off about it actually would be it
was a good flick though yeah it is if
you like I said if you did reanimate her
then obviously you have to see this one
it's almost like it's spiritual sequel
yeah you know it's not the same story
but it's all the same actors very
similar kind of vibe not quite as funny
but they never made a sequel to it
no but you know still fun and fun to
look at and like I said I think the
effects still hold up really well yeah
and it has like a really kind of cool
Lovecraft II and other demand it was all
practical effects you know I mean when
you have the actors there they're
looking at something it's really there
it's not yeah they're actually touching
and there's you grabbing some big rubber
worm and fighting with it you know it's
it's better because like I said CGI
that's all I can think of is like
they're looking at a tennis ball right
now on a green screen and there was
something about you know it wasn't all
about spectacle and being over the top
visuals back then you know let you use
your imagination and then if something
happened in a scene you know like a
monster popped out of another dimension
it wasn't so overwhelming it was just it
was like an occurrence like it's it's
right there so you could deal with it
nowadays it would be
I like LCG and out I mean and it would
look super super impressive you know
like a painting a moving painting but
back in those days it was just a worm
popping out of the damn pile of smoke on
the ground yeah I feel like CGI kind of
puts you at one remove yeah because it's
so big it doesn't look it actually
happens yeah it doesn't look like it
could really happen it doesn't look like
it's happening in the real world
everyone looks like a videogame yeah and
this you know just go downstairs and
there's a bunch of foota slime on the on
the floor you wade through it and a
bunch of damn smoke coming up out of the
slime and a worm jumps out of it yeah
and you actually saw it that's actually
what it was yeah fight it yeah you fight
it in your underwear what they read or
those good [ __ ] yeah like little briefs
or whatever they were like I think a lot
of people and it looks like a man
fighting the best part about it you know
today they try to make that look all
elegant epic yeah well you know
sometimes the [ __ ] worm comes out of
the resonator in the middle of the night
you're sleeping you're just in your
underwear you got to get up and deal
with that Jeff it was actually a worm it
was just a worm like creature it's a
worm like creator they kind of actually
more looked like eels or less than worms
but it might have had a head on it or
mouth opened up like the thing out of
the dune some of them had heads didn't
some of them have head and horns like
inside I don't know man dick don't get
me live yeah so anyway if you haven't
seen it like I said we've done a lot of
Stuart Gordon movies because we're you
know big fans obviously yeah so if you
haven't seen it you probably should go
check it out especially if you really
like to reanimate her here so that'll do
it for this movie review remember if you
like the show to like share subscribe
and all just all your social media if
you'd like to financially supports show
you can do that too and it would be much
appreciated you can go to our patreon
page at patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcast or you can go to our blog which
is 13
clock podcast wordpress.com and there's
a link in the sidebar to a PayPal
account or you can give a one-time
donation if you would like to do so and
remember our regular episodes come out
every Tuesday movie retrospectives like
this one right here come out every
Friday and our 13 o'clock matinee which
is our three movies at the theater that
we saw the previous week that comes out
every Sunday so until next time bye